hi there its senior editor Kevin Van Ord
standing in for reviewer Miguel
concepción to tell you about Call of
Duty advanced warfare what an opening
Call of Duty advanced warfare
establishes the tone of its campaign
early on with big-budget bravado and a
futuristic version of Seoul South Korea
it's an explosive intro that kicks off
the wartime journey of protagonist Jack
Mitchell and soon involves a military
contractor head named Jonathan irons who
is played by an immediately recognizable
Kevin Spacey Mitchell's tours offer a
smattering of memorable missions
including a fast-paced manhunt through
Santorini and several pulse quickening
escape sequences aside from the
positively imaginative to chapter kick
off the one mission that leaves a
lasting impression is a tenth stealth op
that prominently features a grappling
hook even the early focus on your
movement abilities which are granted by
advanced Warfare's exosuit you'd think
that you'd have lots of opportunities to
put those abilities to good use
unfortunately there are too few sections
in which using an EXO ability is
mandatory but the campaign is a terrific
ride as a whole though gameplay does
adhere to call duties linear
first-person shooter level progression
where combat boils down to suppression
of the enemy near and far luckily there
are a few levels that aspire to the wide
maps of the two latest crisis games it's
there that you get to experiment with
new routes and jump and slide around
courtesy of the exosuit gameplay variety
also arrives by way of scoped firearms
would see through walls technology and a
riveting sequence involving a jet ski
with diving capabilities all of this
futuristic tech and atmosphere is
accompanied by a predictable script that
looks to the Past for all the bad guy
one-liners and
eight cartoon dramatics it can muster
day you are afraid you are afraid
because you have been woken in any case
you've seen these settings before the
passages of a naval ship the obligatory
bridge chapter and so forth
luckily the action movie thrills are
still frequent enough to get your pulse
pounding the campaign may not put the
exosuit to frequent use but you can bet
your online competition will you never
forget your first death at the hands of
an online opponent who outmaneuvered you
with a mid-air strafe double jump combo
the moment you witness such a move is
the moment you want to learn it it's one
thing to instantly see the benefits of a
power slide or a double jump it's
another to apply these abilities in
useful and practical ways with great
abilities come expanded loadout options
the pick 10 system that works so well
for call of duty black ops 2 has
appropriately expanded to 13 picks
combat arenas don't change based on
match type you're expected to adapt to
each mode by having a custom loadout at
the ready a self tailored speed based
loadout is crucial for the new
point-based uplink mode this mode takes
much of its inspiration from end to end
goal scoring sports like basketball and
soccer but it isn't just a throwaway
novelty but a hotbed of intense
competition
meanwhile hardpoint not seen since Call
of Duty Black Ops makes a much welcome
return as advance forth harris king of
the hill mode
progressing and obtaining rewards in
advanced Warfare's multiplayer is a
layered experience the supply drop
system grants you random rewards without
risk of unlocking duplicate items the
one exception is if you convert an
unwanted Supply Drop reward into
experience which is a practical option
but it does open the possibility of
unlocking that item again in contrast to
the catastrophes you can trigger and
call of duty ghosts' advanced Warfare's
dynamic events are entirely
anti-climactic a tsunami warning in the
san francisco map might compel you to
search for higher ground only for you to
realize the ensuing flood is laughably
minor it's commendable however that the
multiplayer maps don't heavily borrow
from the single-player campaign but
instead offer new and dramatic locales
in which to destroy your enemies or
perhaps you'd rather make friends
instead in which case you can buddy up
with cooperative teammates in EXO
survival mode co-op maps are divided
into four difficulty tiers partly based
on how the terrain of each setting helps
or hurts your team for example the three
points of entry in the hotel lobby of
the terrace map make this reception area
an ideal home base the challenge arrives
when you must leave the comforts of the
lobby during non defensive missions when
you only have 90 seconds to collect 20
dog tags and a map that is as tall as it
is wide a team that splits up without
pairing up is most likely a dead one the
bio lab map is a fitting starter map but
it's so easy that you'll likely end the
session not because everyone dies but
because everyone's gotten bored and
wants to do something more fun and
interesting
advanced warfare makes for a convincing
foundation of future
to get relatable combat that is worth
exploring and expanding even further the
huge change in player mobility is not so
much a revolution as it is an overdue
retooling career series with yearly
entries for all its flaws and
predictability
advanced warfare still makes you look
forward to a direct sequel
you